تحت شعار اوقفوا القوارب اعلن رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني سوناك قطته الجديده
لمنع المهاجرين الذين يصلون الى البلاد
عبر القناه البحريه التي تفصل بين
بريطانيا وفرنسا وما ان تم الاعلان عن
تفاصيل الخطه حتى اندلع جدل قانوني وحقوق
واسع في بريطانيا بسبب اجراءاتها التي
تغلق الباب نهائيا امام المهاجرين سنه
برره قراره واقراره الخطه بعجز حكومته عن
ايجاد حل القوارب المتدفقه بحسب تعبيره
حيث دافع عن خطته بانه لجا اليها بعد ان
حاول بكل الطرق ولم يبقى امامه سوى حرمان
كل من يصل عن طريق القوارب الصغيره من حق
اللجوء طبعا حكومه سوناك وجدت نفسها امام
معضله تتعلق بالتفاف الالتفاف على قرار
المحكمه الاوروبيه لحقوق الانسان والتي
سبق ان الغت قرار وزاره الداخليه
البريطانيه بشان ترحيل عدد من طالبي
اللجوء الى مشروع القانون هذا والذي ينظر
فيه البرلمان يقضي بان من يصل المملكه
وبطريقه غير قانونيه لن يتمكن من البقاء
او العوده اليها او تقديم طلب لجوء فيها
وسيتم ترحيله الى بلده او المكان الذي قدم
منه او وجهه ثالثه يقولون امنه وتمثل قضيه
المهاجرين غير عبر المونش ازمه متجدده
طبعا بين فرنسا ولندن وفي ضوء ذلك سيتوجه
سوناك الجمعه الى باريس للقاء ماكرون
الرئيس الفرنسي في قمه سيكون عنوانها
معالجه ازمه الهجره غير الشرعيه وتعزيز
التعاون بين البلدين في هذا المجال